There are many different ways to
communicate in today's business
environment, but one of the most common
that we've seen year after year is
email. This makes a very attractive
attack vector for anyone who wants to
gain access to data that might be on the
inside of a corporate network. After
all, who doesn't trust the information
that's in their email inbox? This is
something we use every day, multiple
times a day to communicate with people
all over the world. And every person in
our company has an email address.
Unfortunately, not everyone understands
the security associated with that email
address. And that's where we have
problems with a business email
compromise. Often there is a significant
social engineering aspect to these email
messages that entices the user to click
on a malicious link. This makes it very
difficult to stop something like a
business email compromise because our
automated systems aren't designed to
stop every possible instance of a social
engineering attack.
When creating this presentation, I went
back to the last month or so of attacks
that had anything to do with an email
compromise, and we were able to find
many instances of email being the method
that attackers use to gain access to
this data. One of these examples had a
user receiving an email from their title
company while they were in the middle of
closing on some real estate. Although
this email seemed to be from their title
company, in reality it was being sent
from an attacker making the email appear
as if it was from this title company.
And this email message contained wire
information on where they should send
their funds for the closing of this real
estate. Of course, everything in this
email message was false. and the wire
transfer sent money to the attackers
rather than sending it to the title
company. Another common email attack is
one where you receive a message from the
CEO of your company asking you to
perform a task where you would purchase
gift cards that they plan on using for
employee awards. For this attack, all of
the codes associated with those gift
cards are being emailed to this CEO of
your company who in reality is an
attacker that has nothing to do with
your organization. And another attack
might have the attacker gaining access
to an internal email address and using
that email address to change information
about the employees banking information.
For example, the attacker could be
sending an email message that has your
name on it, but it's asking your payroll
department to change your direct deposit
information. This means during the next
pay cycle, your attacker is going to be
paid with your wages instead of it
arriving in your normal bank account.
Very often this type of attack is
successful because the attacker spends a
lot of time planning out this attack and
orchestrating exactly what they plan on
doing. In the first step, the attacker
is going to identify the target they're
going to use. They might use company
information or social media details to
identify an individual within the
organization that they can use for this
business email compromise. In many of
these instances, the attacker is
becoming more familiar with the end user
by sending messages pretending to be
someone who could be trusted. These
emails might contain detailed
information about projects that are
going on, or it may be simply small talk
occurring between two people in two
different organizations. Once the victim
is comfortable, the attacker then
executes the process that will gather
data, money, or whatever the attacker is
looking for. In this particular
instance, for example, the attacker
could provide that fake bank information
and then simply sit back and wait for
those funds to arrive in the attacker's
account. And if it worked one time, then
it could possibly work again. So, the
attackers could visit that victim again
and have them perform a similar process
in the hopes that they have not yet
discovered that this is actually a
business email compromise.
Sometimes attackers are communicating
with you over a legitimate email that
they've compromised at a third party or
they might be using a domain in an email
that appears to be from a trusted source
but in reality there might be a
misspelling. For example, my email
address is not jamesprofessor messor.com
where professor messer is misspelled and
only has one s. If you saw that in an
email message coming through though, you
might not even recognize that it's
misspelled and you may just assume that
you're communicating with the legitimate
person. Spear fishing is a common aspect
of this business email compromise
because the attacker needs to find
someone who has access to data or access
to money. This is often someone in the
accounting department, for example. So
it might be a good idea to provide some
additional training to the accounting
team so that they can look for and
perhaps prevent these problems from
occurring. This is also very often part
of a larger breach that may not have
anything to do with your company. For
example, the attacker may have
compromised the email at one of your
vendors and now you're receiving
messages from that legitimate vendor
email address, but they're really being
authored by the attacker. And if you
ever feel that sense of urgency and that
somebody is pushing you to do something
very quickly, this may be part of a
business email compromise. So, it's
always a good idea to verify what you're
doing. If you receive a message from the
CEO, it might be a good idea to check in
with the CEO's assistant to see if they
really were looking for gift cards. One
simple phone call can often stop these
from occurring. And if you train your
user community to look for these very
unusual situations and to always know
exactly who they can contact in the IT
department, then you may have a way to
stop these issues before they ever
become a business email compromise.